hi this module is about linear
classification we're going to go through
a linear classification via a simple
example just like we did for linear
regression
so as before we have training data which
consists of a set of examples
and each example
is now going to be an input x1 x2
followed by a label y
so we have three examples here the input
zero two
is has output one
minus two zero has output one
and minus one minus one
sorry one minus one has output minus one
we can visualize these points just the
input part on the
on the 2d diagram so where i'm plotting
x1 by x2
so here is 0 2
and i'm coloring it
orange to denote that as a positive
point
this is minus 2 0 that's also orange
because it's positive and here is ma 1
minus 1
which is blue because it's labeled as
negative
so given these points we want to design
a learning algorithm
that can output a predictor in
classification it's known as a
classifier
and this classifier can take new inputs
and crank them through the classifier
and produce an output label
and so this is demonstrated um as
follows on the plot as follows so the
classifier in
classification is going to be
represented by a decision boundary
so this decision boundary carves up the
space into a region
where
the points are labeled positive
and the region where the points are
labeled minus
so two zero is going to be predicted as
a minus one in this case
okay as before we have three design
decisions we need to settle
first which classifiers are possible
and this is a question of the hypothesis
class we're going to consider
are the decision boundaries going to be
straight or can they be curved
second how good is a classifier this is
a question of a loss function
and third how do we compute
the best classifier
aka the classifier with the lowest loss
and that's going to be a question of the
optimization algorithm
so
before we begin talking about
the design space of
the hypothesis class i'm going to focus
on an example linear classifier here
so we have f of x equals
and then we have i'm going to define
this weight vector w
to be
minus 0.6 comma 0.6
and i'm going to take the dot product
with
a feature vector
which is going to be
just the identity feature vector mapping
to x1 comma x2 remember x is
now a two-dimensional
list of
two numbers
and then i'm going to take this dot
product i'm going to take the sign
and remember the sign of a scalar is
equal to
plus one if that scalar is positive
minus one if it's negative
and zero
if it is
zero
okay so
um how
let's see what this classifier does on
some points
so each point is x1 x2 so let's look at
zero
okay so let's look at where 0 2 is
on the plot 0 2 is right here
and i'm going to represent it by this
vector here
and now
this vector is phi of x
w is going to be this vector here that's
the weight vector
and
the dot product remembering from linear
algebra is the cosine of this angle
and in particular the dot product is
positive if and only if this angle is
acute
and it's
negative if the angle is up to so in
this case it is
acute so therefore this point is going
to be classified as positive
so let's take another point so
minus 2 0
minus 2 0 is here
and this angle is also acute so
therefore
this point is also labeled as positive
and the third point is one minus one so
one minus one is over here
and now this angle between the red and
the blue is obtuse
therefore the
sign is negative
so you can
understand how a classifier behaves
geometrically
um but you can also do this uh
symbolically by following the math so if
you plug in the first point 0 2
you take the sign
the dot product is 1.2 you take the sign
and you get 1.
if you take the second point
the sign is also 1.2 you get 1. and you
take the third point the sign is minus
1.2 and the sine of minus 1.2 is minus
1.
okay so you can kind of see the pattern
now
so
we have
any point over here that forms an acute
angle with this wave vector
minus 0.6.6 is going to be labeled as
positive
and anything that forms an obtuse angle
with this wave vector is going to be
labeled as negative
and the decision boundary is exactly
those points
that are perpendicular and indeed you
can see that this is a right angle here
these are the points which the
classifier just doesn't know if it's
positive or negative
okay
so that was one particular classifier um
that was this one
but we can imagine other ones
so we can imagine this purple classifier
which has weights
0.5 and 1
and that corresponds to
this point here
so that is 0.51 and remember the
decision boundary is the thing that is
perpendicular or normal to the weight
vector and in 2d it's given by this line
so this purple classifier will classify
all these points plus and all of these
points minus
in general
the binary classifier f sub w
uh where w is the weights of a
particular input x is equal to
you take the dot product
and then you take the sign of that dot
product
okay
and the hypothesis class as before is
just simply the set of all possible
classifiers by ranging the weights over
any two real numbers
so that's the hypothesis class now let's
go on to the second design decision
what is a good loss function
okay so let's take our purple classifier
and some training data
and we're going to evaluate how
good this classifier is on this training
data okay so the training data uh
let's go through this so here's the
classifier and the first point is zero
two
and this was labeled as uh plus one okay
so that is this
point over here
um
and this classifier is predicted
correctly because it's on this side it's
a positive label and it's the classifier
also thinks it's positive
so therefore we expect low loss
whereas this point over here
minus 2 0
is labeled as positive but it's on the
other side of the decision boundary and
therefore it's classified incorrectly
on this point
1 minus 1 minus 1
is over here and it's is labeled in the
training data as minus
it is on this side of the decision
boundary so it's predicted as minus
therefore it is labeled correctly as
well
so to formalize this we're going to
define something called the zero one
loss
and just like any loss function it takes
in a particular example and a wave
vector
and it looks at the prediction
and the the target and says do they
disagree
and if they disagree
then this indicator function will return
one
and if they agree then the indicator
function returns zero so this is a zero
on loss so mathematically you can walk
through these calculations you plug in
the first point
and you look at the sign
the sign here is going to be
two
the dot product of two is one
they don't disagree so that's a zero the
second point
they do disagree so the loss is one and
the third point they also don't disagree
and the loss is zero
and as before the training loss
over the entire training set of examples
is
just simply the average over the per
example losses and in this case it's one
third
so before we move on to the design
decision of how to optimize the loss
function let's spend some time
understanding two important concepts so
we can rewrite the zero loss in a
slightly different way
so recall that the predicted label on
the particular input is the sign of the
dot product and
the target label is y
so
the score
is something that we've seen before a
score on example is simply this
expression
which is a dot product inside the sign
and while the sign is just one or minus
one
um the score is a real number which
uh intuitively represents how confident
we are in predicting plus one
so points over here have large dot
product with this purple weight vector
and have high score um ones on the
decision boundary have zero score ones
over here have um very negative scores
the second concept is that of a margin
which takes takes into account the
target label
so the margin on the example is simply
the score
times
the correct target label
and this measures how correct we are
notice that you can be confident but not
correct
uh important life lesson
so um
so if y is positive
then the margin is going to be high when
this number is hugely positive and if y
is minus one
then the margin is going to be high when
this score is hugely negative
okay so with these two definitions in
mind we can now
look at the zero and loss again remember
the zero on loss is an indicator of
whether the prediction and target
disagree
but now we can represent it in terms of
the margin
so this is the expression it's basically
when the margin is less or equal to zero
so remember
positive margin means that we're
classifying correctly a negative margin
means that we're classifying incorrectly
and we can visualize this
as follows so here i'm plotting the
margin
against the loss
and if the margin is positive greater
than zero the loss is zero and if the
margin is less or equal to zero then the
loss is one
okay so that is zero one losses
expressed in the margin
okay so now let's optimize the third
design decision let's do
um
optimize the training loss
we want to find the minimum weight
vector that minimizes this expression
which is the average of the individual
losses
and let's just use gradient descent as
we did before
and to do it we have to compute the
gradients so the gradient of the
training loss is equal to the sum over
the gradient of the individual losses
you look at the individual losses take
the gradient and now you have to take
the gradient with respect to this
indicator function
and now that's where things go uh wrong
so if you remember what this
the loss looks like
it's looks like this step function
right and what's the gradient of this
function
well
it's zero almost everywhere it's zero
zero zero zero zero and then there's
this discontinuity where it's undefined
and then zero zero zero zero
so remember what gradient descent's
trying to do it computes the gradient
and then it moves in that direction and
if the gradient is zero brain descent
just gets stuck and it can't go anywhere
so gradient descent will not work
on the xeron loss
so one kind of technical note is that if
someone asks you why can't you do
gradient descent on the zero and loss uh
initial reaction might be because it's
not differentiable and that is true it's
not differentiable but it's only
differentiable not differentiable at one
point
the real reason is that the gradient is
zero everywhere and with a zero gradient
you just can't make any progress
so how do you fix this there's a few
things you can do but one example is
what is called the hinge loss so
pictorially the hinge loss is just
another loss function
um the one in green here
and i'm plotting it on this margin
versus loss plot the zero velocity looks
like this and the hinge loss looks like
that
so it's the maximum of two lines one is
this descending line and one is this
flat
line at zero
okay so formally what is this so the
hinge loss
is
equal to
the max over two things the first is
um one minus
the margin
okay so this complicated expression is
just the margin
and the zero function
okay corresponding these two arguments
to the max corresponding to these two
regions of
the the hinge loss
okay so let's interpret this a little
bit so
if the margin is greater than or equal
to one
then the hinge loss is zero
but once the margin starts dipping below
one
then the hinge loss starts growing
linearly
with
the margin violation
and why is there a one here and not at
zero um well this is because we asked
the classifier to predict not only
correctly but by a positive margin of
safety
and just an aside this one could really
be two or three or any number as long as
it's positive and its magnitude
effectively determines uh the
regularization strength if you're using
regularizers
don't worry if you didn't get that
okay so also notice that the hinge loss
is an upper bound on the zero loss so
this is cool because suppose you
optimize the hinge loss and you drive it
down driving down this thing is going to
start pushing on the zero loss
more or less and particularly if you get
this hinge loss of zero
then what is the zero loss well it's
also going to be zero so that's that's a
nice fact
so here's a minor digression there's a
lot of other loss functions here is the
logistic loss and we can just plot it on
this diagram and you see that the
logistic loss doesn't have this kink in
it it has a smooth transition between
something that's growing linearly to
something that fades away to zero
and the
the key property of the logistic loss is
that even if you were out here
so if you have a margin of 2
then you're classifying correctly and
the hinge loss would say you get zero
loss and you don't need to do anything
but the logistic loss is greedy it says
well you still have a little bit of a
loss and if you try to minimize the
logistic loss you're just going to try
to
keep on pushing this margin far out as
possible
so the logistic loss is differentiable
everywhere and smooth and it's nice and
it's typically known as logistic
regression because it has connections to
probability
okay so let's now go back to the hinge
loss
here is our friend the hinge loss
and here is the expression for the hinge
loss and remember it's the maximum of
two expressions
um this decreasing align part and then
the zero part in orange and blue
respectively
okay so now if we want to apply gradient
descent to the hinge loss we have to
take the gradient
so how do we take the gradient so the
gradient of the loss
hinge is equal to
and now we have this max thing okay
which might be a little bit scary but if
you look up here
we can just do this kind of visually so
what is the slope here well the slope
here is whatever the slope of the orange
part is and what is the slope here it's
the slope of this
blue part
and so now we just have to switch
between the two cases
so in particular if
the margin
is orange apart
is greater than zero
that means we're in this region
and then the gradient is just going to
be the gradient of this expression one's
a constant it's so it's going to be
minus
we're differentiating with respect to w
so and phi of x y is a constant so it's
just going to be phi of x y
and then if this condition doesn't hold
otherwise that means we're in this
region
and what is the gradient of zero well
that's the world's easiest differential
uh calculus problem and it's uh zero
okay so this is the gradient of the
hinge loss
and just to kind of sanity check things
so if you have a pick up an example
and it's on this side over here then the
gradient is going to be zero and you're
not going to update your weights
on the other hand if you are over here
then the gradient will be non-zero in
particular it's going to be minus v of x
y
okay so now let's put things together
and revisit our
example so here's the purple classifier
over here
and
here we have some training data and
we're going to try to compute the hinge
loss on this training data along with
its gradient
okay so
remember the hinge loss is this
expression
so let's look at the first point 0 2
0 2 is here and it's labeled as a
positive so if you go and you plug
that point into the hinge loss then you
get a max over one minus the margin
and zero so what is the margin here
well it's this dot product which happens
to be two
so we have 1 minus 2 minus 1
and my max of minus 1 and 0 is 0. and
that agrees with our intuition that the
loss here should be 0 because it's
correctly classified and correctly
classified by a margin of 2.
and now let's look at the second point
minus 2
0
so if we compute the loss here
we see that the loss is actually 2.
so notice that even though we are
getting
this oh so this loss is actually 2
and that makes sense because we
misclassified this point
so now if we look at the third
point here
minus 1
sorry 1 minus 1
then the loss on this example is 1.5
so notice that even though we're
classifying this point correctly we're
still incurring a lot because the margin
was only 0.5 and didn't meet the
threshold
okay so
or i guess the loss is maybe 1.5
sorry the margin is 0.5 but the loss is
1.5
so
now we can also compute the gradients
here so the loss on the first
a point is zero because the loss is zero
and generally
not always if the loss is zero then the
gradient will be zero as well
and on the second
one the loss is not zero so we have a
non-zero gradient which is
minus of e of x
y so it's this
part
um
times this minus sign
and the third
point
also has positive loss so it has a
positive gradient 1 minus 1.
now
we can compute the train loss which is
the average over the losses that gives
us 1.17 and the gradient of the train
loss is just the average of the
gradients and that gives us 1 minus 0.33
okay so
let us now move on let's concretize this
in python
okay so let's uh remember last time
we coded up gradient descent for
uh
linear regression so now i'm gonna just
copy this
um
object against that send hinge
and do it for the hinge loss okay so i'm
going to use this as a starting point
and
i'm going to just change a few things um
let's
change the training examples because now
we're working with this training data
so we have uh just to keep track of
things so this is x y pairs
so x now
is um
zero two
one
and then the second point is minus two
zero
and the third point is one minus one
and so we have three points x y where x
is uh uh
triple
okay so phi
is uh just going to be
um
you know x
and
uh
the wave dimension of the white vector
is still two
and now the key thing we have to do is
change the uh the definition of the loss
so now let us see so we before we have
the average over a sum here and instead
of the square loss i'm going to make
this the hinge loss so the hinge loss is
max over 1 minus the margin
okay and 0.
all right so this is max over one minus
the margin and zero
and the gradient of that
um is going to be
so
um let's actually just copy this down
let's delete this
to not confuse ourselves
um so remember if the
this first expression
is greater than 0
then the gradient is minus
phi of x times y
if
we're on that side of
the curve and otherwise it's just going
to be
zero
okay so that's it we just changed the
training examples and changed
the
definition of the loss function
and
the optimization algorithm we don't
actually have to change at all
okay
so let's run this and see what we get
okay so here's where you said it starts
out with w equals zero and then it
starts moving w to
0.5 uh minus 0.55
you see that the the train loss is
decreasing nicely and actually in this
case it gets to
zero which means that we
remember the hinge loss is upper bound
on zero and loss so that means the zero
loss is also zero
and the gradient also vanishes
and becomes zero meaning that we
converged
okay so just to recap all we did here
was change the training examples the
feature riser
and uh redefine the loss and it's great
that we didn't have to touch the
optimization algorithm because this was
meant to be a generic piece of code
all right so
let us summarize
and in particular i'm going to contrast
regression with classification since
we've seen two of them so far
so
the key
quantity
that drives the prediction in both cases
is the score the dot product between the
weight vector and the feature vector
and in regression the prediction is
exactly just a raw score while in
classification you stick it through the
sine function so you get a one
or a minus one
how the prediction is related to the
target
well in regression we looked at the
residual which was the score minus y
and in classification we're looking at
the margin so in regression low residual
was good
in classification high margin is good
because we want score and y to have the
same sign
using those quantities we can define
loss functions
so in regression we looked at the square
laws but as i mentioned briefly you can
also do the absolute deviation loss in
classification the story becomes a
little bit stranger
because we generally care about the zero
loss that's our misclassification rate
but we can't optimize it so we have to
come up with a surrogate loss function
like the hinge loss which we went into
depth and the logistic loss which we
briefly mentioned
and given the loss functions
in both cases we use the gradient
descent algorithm to optimize the loss
function
that's it that concludes the unit on
linear classification thanks for
listening